The worldwide death toll for victims of the coronavirus reaches 425...
...after Hong Kong suffered its first death from the illness.
More than 20,000 confirmed cases have been reported around the world.
In Syria, the UN says more than 520,000 Syrians have been displaced since December 1.
An additional 280,000 people are at risk of also being displaced...
...if current military operations continue.
In Kenya, 14 elementary school students were killed in a stampede with nearly 40 others injured.
An investigation has been launched to find out why the stampede occurred.
Heavy rainfall has caused flooding along the Neckar River in southern Germany.
More rain is expected in the coming days.
Finally from Malawi, the country's constitutional court annulled its May presidential election...
...after verifying only 23% of the results.
A fresh vote will be scheduled within 150 days.